I'm supposed to um have you gone hog
hunting out there yet so I did you know
the it's crazy I took me and my son and
I just didn't post it cuz you never know
because it is it is a pretty intense uh
video I've seen the videos of the guys
on the helicopter just mowing down pigs
we got in the trenches with them it
wasn't that we in the middle of the
night in the pitch black did you stab
any huh did you nah no you a have to do
that I'm going to I'm going to show you
I just never you know I never post so I
got invited to go to Texas with OT and
he said baby we going to go hog hunted
baby and he's like we're going to be in
the back of a truck with a machine gun
just mowing down pigs and I'm a huge
animal lover but I don't love them
enough not to eat them obviously I
wouldn't eat I wouldn't dare eating no
goddamn hog me I'll eat the swine the
swine is divine I mean not that type of
hog we talking about wild boyss you a
you don't want to eat that see but then
I I I I understand why they want you to
kill the Hogs cuz they are an invasive
species in Texas for people don't know
they [__] up crops they kill uh pets
they they're just they're just not the
nicest pigs but they're also the literal
pig that Pumba is in The Lion King so
you know I'm probably going to end up
going and just murdering a bunch of
pumbas in the middle of I don't look at
it like that but if you ever get caught
in the vicinity of one of them you [__]
are they mean are they nice so maybe got
they probably got one of the most
vicious bites you going you know what
maybe that is um the more dangerous way
I'm going to approach this but it'll
make me sleep at night better so I don't
feel like a murderer is I'm going to
just get out of the truck and I'm going
to wait for them to come at me and then
I'm going to kill them oh it's not going
to be that easy and they fast as [__] so
we out there we have to use night vision
to see him from a distance wow I've seen
the videos listen I've seen the Tik toks
they it's crazy that's the next Vlog
we're doing we're going to
Texas oh wow that is a look at that
Pig's teeth
bro do do you um stuff that and hanging
on the wall at home h no uhuh you see me
I'm going to take one of them and I'm
going to put it on the podcast
set we're going to do the
Taxidermy he you do know they come in
packs so you it can be a bunch yeah
that's you in trouble if you don't know
what you're doing or you ain't out there
with the right people you [__] what yeah
I mean do is is it a thing you could
inform me do people pay to go hunt them
I don't know you know uh people get paid
to go hunt them because so we can make
money yeah because that's why so the
people who go up in the helicopters they
definitely get paid the people who take
people out you know what I'm saying
because is they so much of a problem
yeah I've heard that they're really bad
for the you know environment and but
they're also like you know little furry
little all right trying to pit one to
tell me that my friend has a pig yeah
but not that kind of a no he's got a pig
like a little pig's dope but boy so not
a boar yeah boar is not to be played
with that'd be a pretty sick if you ever
did actually you won't even be able to
put a boy down with a handgun like that
notless well I so so I had heard uh I
was talking with uh ot's pops and he was
saying that sometimes you got to shoot
it and then you got to slice it from
behind which to me sounds like something
I'm just not willing to do yeah I ain't
got that close to it I'm good I don't
want to ever stab anything unless I have
to yeah definitely if you got to protect
your family if you have to you're going
to stab somebody yeah with no hesitation
but I'm not going to do it like just for
the [__] cuz it's
Monday like it's Monday let's go [__]
slice some Pig's throats out here um all
right so the new album is uh Stuck In
Motion stuck in MO 18 tracks 18 tracks
it's your first album in a while yeah I
think it's what been 5 years as far as a
real album yeah it's been it's been a
minute you know I threw out songs and
little tapes and stuff but n this is and
even when I threw out tapes it kind of
got lost in the shuffle cuz again we
dealing with life yeah but this is the
first real album that I'm actually you
know crazy thing as much as y'all know
me and I be around y'all I don't really
do interviews yeah you don't do a lot
you see what I'm saying so when when you
see me talking doing that then it's it's
that time it's time you're on you're on
you're on the campaign yeah yeah
definitely there it is man well listen
go get the album go support it go buy a
a bump boox they're incredible always
bump boox docomo xes make sure y'all go
get that they're amazing yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh if you break a cord though
you're [__] cuz I so the thing is they
just got to reach out to us a lot of
people do that and once they lose a cord
they be like man my box ain't working
like if you didn't give me the
opportunity I could I there was so I you
you had given me like when me and had
interviewed you a while ago I think
Jeezy came up to the station at the same
time when I had my daughter with me yeah
you had your daughter with you you had
given me like a small like one of the
smaller ones right and um the cord went
out so I tried to buy that cord on
Amazon I I bought like three different
cords and none of them would keep this
thing on yeah and I called when you guys
open the store I was like oh this is
great this isn't too far I called the
[__] store said hey guys I got this
model uh can I just go up there and buy
a cord and they were like nah we don't
sell just the cord and I was like well
sh I don't know why the [__] you didn't
just call me cuz I you know I I did call
you and then you just sent me a whole
new bump box that's the easy way too
yeah so that's when I got the big doggy
style one and doggy style is my favorite
hip-hop album ever oh yeah well top
three you know at any given day it could
be number one so do style was a classic
for sure um but yeah so go get a bump
box there incredible and a slapstick
yeah yeah and some headphones and by the
way the headphones sound amazing I mean
the ones I have are probably four or 5
years old at this point but they sound
[__] great they the people didn't
know so you know it's crazy people
didn't really realize how dope they were
now everybody trying to get them and we
don't have them cuz at the time there
was like those beat studios and yours
sounded way better cuz those were the
ones I was I was using at the radio but
then I got the ones from you and they
sounded [__] way better yeah and you
know once we were out everybody like
[__] man we need to get that and that's
like it's too late but but the in ear is
the way to go that's what everyone's
doing and the thing is with me being in
music my part in the Rob and and
everybody over there is like we always
going to make sure our [__] louder more
basic more clear yeah so that's the
thing we go for you know we not trying
to we're not trying to hit a quick lick
for sure yeah yeah so no for sure the N
is going to kill um my glass is coming
out with um Habibi glasses that's going
to be crazy um the movie the cartoon
movie coming me and Mazy still got a
movie unreleased in the whole I just saw
you posted with yeah yeah we you guys
got a whole album together yeah we
already had one out we got a second one
just sitting up wait how long ago did
you guys put that out like 206 W yeah
yeah cuz for people who don't know Mazy
has albums out with artists that you you
before you even like cuz I I I really
the first time I interviewed Mazi was
2017 and I think he had the [__] with
you he had the [__] with gun play out
yeah he's got a bunch of collab albums
that's my little brother for real for
real like our relationship is it ain't
even really about the music for sure